bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
cada 1º de mayo una gran parte del
planeta celebra el día del trabajador a
lo largo de las últimas décadas esta
jornada ha servido como acto de
reivindicación principal de sindicatos y
obreros hasta el punto de convertirse en
uno de los feriados no religiosos más
ampliamente celebrados en todo el mundo
pero de dónde viene esta festividad y en
qué países se celebra
como se observa en este mapa
prácticamente todo el mundo celebra este
día algo que no es tan habitual en otras
festividades las excepciones las
encontramos en algunos países de áfrica
medio oriente y asia y en eeuu y canadá
donde decidieron desligar lo del
movimiento obrero por miedo a que el
socialismo arraigarán estas naciones y
es que la gestación de lo que hoy
conocemos como el 1º de mayo se dio en
el primer congreso de la segunda
internacional socialista celebrado en
parís en julio de 1889 aquí los partidos
socialistas del mundo acordaron celebrar
este día como una jornada de homenaje al
proletariado la fecha se escogió en
honor a los martín chicago una serie de
sindicalistas estadounidenses que fueron
condenados a muerte en 1886 luego de una
huelga que reclamaba la implementación
de la jornada laboral de 8 horas la
justicia los acusó de explosionar un
artefacto que mató a varios policías sin
prácticamente pruebas y en un juicio
cuestionado desde ese momento el primero
de mayo fue el día en que los
trabajadores de los países
industrializados en la época reclamaron
la jornada laboral de 8 horas y el
festivo para esa fecha algo que con el
tiempo se fue logrando en varias
naciones el objetivo principal era
establecer un sistema que dignificará la
calidad de vida del trabajador por medio
de 8 horas de trabajo 8 de ocio y 8 de
descanso en rusia no entré en vigor
hasta la formación de la unión soviética
en 1917 mientras que en naciones como
españa portugal o francia este derecho
no se obtuvo hasta 1919 otros países no
verían resultados hasta la década de
1920 o incluso más tarde
pero el éxito de seguimiento que tuvo
esta jornada año tras año no se puede
entender sin conocer las condiciones de
la mayoría de los trabajadores
industriales para finales del siglo 19 y
principios del 20 que en general eran
muy malas los obreros sufrían jornadas
de sol a sol tenían salarios irrisorios
y en muchos casos se veían obligados a
trabajar desde niños un contexto idóneo
para que florecieran las doctrinas
comunistas y anarquista en una parte
importante de la clase proletaria estos
partidos y sindicatos
aprovechaban el primero de mayo para
exhibir fuerza ante los estados con
manifestaciones muy multitudinarias
en muchos casos estas protestas también
exigían el cambio de régimen
especialmente a partir de 1917 cuando se
empezó a tener la referencia del
comunismo en la unión soviética en los
países donde triunfó la revolución
socialista y se implementó este sistema
se siguió conmemorando y celebrando como
uno de los días más importantes en el
calendario en plena guerra fría esta
jornada sirvió para muchas de estas
naciones como un momento de veneración
al líder exhibición de la fortaleza
militar y desfile es llamativo como el
carácter reivindicativo con el que
inicialmente se forjó este día quedó de
lado en sustitución por algo más festivo
por otra parte en el bloque occidental
los objetivos fueron cambiando después
de la segunda guerra mundial la
consolidación del estado del bienestar
pensiones dignas salud universal o un
salario mínimo fueron las victorias que
poco a poco el movimiento obrero fue
obteniendo pero con la llegada de la
década de 1980 hubo dos acontecimientos
que hicieron que el sindicalismo
perdiera fuerza en los países
occidentales la reconversión industrial
y la deslocalización
unidos y europa dejaron de tener tanta
población dependiente de la industria
para focalizarse en una economía de
mercado y servicios algo que hizo que
una parte significativa del tejido
industrial
desapareciera para ser llevado a países
en vías de desarrollo a pesar de la
resistencia del sindicalismo en los 80
lo cierto es que finalmente no lograron
mantener la industria y esto debilitó la
fuerza que tenían antaño los movimientos
obreros y como consecuencia la
importancia reivindicativa del primero
de mayo eso no significa que las
protestas de cada año cesarán nunca lo
hicieron pero su importancia relativa
para conseguir objetivos disminuyó al
igual que el número de afiliados a los
sindicatos en todo el mundo el poder de
estas organizaciones de corte socialista
y sobre todo anarquista ha desaparecido
prácticamente en naciones como eeuu y en
europa los sindicatos tradicionales de
países como francia españa o reino unido
siguen existiendo aunque en la mayoría
de los casos con un tono mucho más
moderado que hace unos años pero a pesar
de esta notable pérdida de fuerza las
reivindicaciones en muchos de los países
todavía siguen existiendo aunque se
afrontan de una forma diferente el
primero de mayo ha dejado atrás
proclamas universales como la adopción
de las 8 horas por reivindicaciones más
nacionales o locales además para una
parte de la población esta fecha ha
pasado a ser simplemente una jornada de
descanso más en homenaje a los
trabajadores sacando del contexto
cualquier tipo de reivindicación una
situación que también ha sido alentada
por algunos estados al cambiar el nombre
de la jornada por el día del trabajo en
lugar del trabajador sea como fuere la
importancia histórica de este día
continúa y con ella su legado con esto
concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]